Thank you all for coming, and please take your seats.
So it's a great honor for me and pleasure to
chair this session and
invite these fantastic speakers.
We're going to be discussing the microbiome with relation to CAR
T cell therapy, and I think a little bit more broadly to
immunotherapy as well. I have just a few intro slides
for those that are new to microbiome research.
So microbiome research is the study of microbes, which include bacteria,
fungi, and viruses that live on and within
us, and how they impact on health and disease.
The field has been biased, I think, substantially towards
bacteria,
for good reasons. Bacteria make up the bulk of our
microbiome density
and are a little bit easier to study.
The tools are better established for bacteria.
But fungi and viruses have also been shown by many investigators to
be important and I think is a rising area of
research.
So we each harbor on the order of 100 trillion
microbes. They make up for about 3% of our body
mass. Their cells
outnumber our cells up to tenfold, and their
genes outnumber our genes also up to tenfold.
A lot of microbiome research has been focused on the GI tract because
that's where the highest density of microbes are found.
These are some of the clinical areas where microbiome scientists have
found strong associations. So, I've grouped them here by
topic. So the first group here is metabolic disorders like
obesity, atherosclerosis, diabetes.
Nutrition is intimately linked with the
microbiome because the microbes are involved in digestion of
food. A variety of inflammatory disorders are
modulated by the microbiome.
And then the next bubble there is neurological
diseases. So there's a lot of active research on the
gut-brain axis. And then finally, I think of interest
to this audience is
how the microbiome can relate to cancer development, so
carcinogenesis,
mutations,
cancer treatment toxicities
such as graft versus host disease, which is what I've studied, or
checkpoint inhibitor colitis. And then finally,
the topic of the session, cancer treatment responses, including,
in particular, immunotherapy such as CAR T cell therapy.
So with that, I'll introduce our first speaker, Melody Smith from Stanford
University. Thank you.
All right. Good morning, everyone.
So I will be presenting on the topic of the impact of the intestinal
microbiome on CAR T cell therapy with a discussion
both of preclinical and clinical insights on this topic.
The research on the intestinal microbiome in CAR T cell
therapy is still relatively new and emerging, and so I'm going to give
you a broad overview of both of those spaces and sort of where the
field is at this time.
These are my disclosures.
So we know in the study of the microbiome that a
variety of host intrinsic and host extrinsic
factors can impact the efficacy of cancer
immunotherapy. You see listed some of those
factors. And where I want to start with the beginning of this talk is
discuss medications and how these medications impact
the microbiome and can lead to what we call dysbiosis or
disruption of the microbiome. We know that of the various
medications that can impact the intestinal microbiome,
antibiotics are one of the most disruptive.
So as an entry point to the discussion of the microbiome in CAR T cell
therapy, I'll start there.
I do want to highlight that these insights in terms of the
microbiome are
based on or really have a strong foundation in other studies of
the microbiome, not only immune checkpoint blockade, but also
allogeneic transplant research.
As Rob alluded to, there's a really large amount of
data with over a decade of literature supporting
that the intestinal microbiome impacts graft versus host disease outcomes
in the allo transplant space and also increases antibiotic resistance.
And I'm going to talk to you about the insights in terms of how antibiotic
exposures prior to CAR T cell therapy are associated with decreased
progression-free survival, decreased overall survival, and
increased neurotoxicity.
So here are the CAR T cell therapies that have been FDA approved
targeting both CD19 and BCMA targets.
What we know is that these therapies have led to
really notable advances in clinical outcomes for patients
with relapse refractory B cell malignancies and multiple myeloma.
However, patients still either don't respond or might have
limited duration of remission, and this is one of the factors that led
us to investigate how host factors, specifically the microbiome,
may modulate these responses.
Before beginning to talk about antibiotics, however, I do want to highlight
that antibiotic treatment is needed in the CAR T cell setting.
I'm showing here retrospective data from a cohort of patients treated at
Fred Hutchinson Institute in Seattle.
They evaluated 694 patients and noted
that of those 694 patients, there were 517
events of mostly Grade 1 to 2 CRS, or
cytokine release syndrome.Of those patients who had
CRS, only 19 had events of bacteremia
that were treated with specific antibiotics to target those
bacteria. And so what we know, again, is that fever is the
early presentation of CRS in our patients who are receiving CAR T-cell therapy, and
a small subset of them may have true bacteremias, which require
antibiotic treatment. So the take home message being that antibiotic
treatment is needed in our immunocompromised patients who have fever after
CAR T-cell therapy, but antibiotic stewardship will
likely lead to improved outcomes.
And I'll show you the data that supports that.
So several years ago, we launched a
collaboration between Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center, when I was there as a
postdoc in the lab of Marcel van den Brink, with investigators at the
University of Pennsylvania, and we investigated a cohort of
228 patients who received CD19-targeted CAR
T-cell therapy for either non-Hodgkin's lymphoma or B-cell
acute lymphoblastic leukemia. Here I'm showing you that
data where we looked at exposed as any patients who
received any antibiotic in the four weeks prior to CAR T-cell
therapy, versus those who didn't receive antibiotics.
And we noted that those patients who'd received antibiotics had decreased
overall survival. A subsequent study
has also evaluated patients who received prophylactic and
non-prophylactic antibiotics, and they classified
them as either high, more than one line of antibiotics, or low, no or
one line. And both in the prophylactic antibiotic space
as well as in the non-prophylactic antibiotic space, they did
observe that patients had decreased progression-free
survival. However, given that not all
antibiotics are equally damaging to the gut, some of these antibiotics are
prophylactic. For example, trimethoprim sulfamethoxazole or
Bactrim, which is used to treat for PJP prophylaxis.
We know that not all antibiotics are equally damaging to the gut.
We focused in on antibiotics that target obligate anaerobes,
which are gut commensals, which play an important role in gut homeostasis.
So we looked at this classification of
piperacillin-tazobactam, imipenem, and meropenem or
PIM in that same period of time, four weeks prior to CAR T-cell
therapy. And as you can see here, there was a much greater
impact in terms of decrease in overall survival.
I'm not showing it here today just for succinctness and the sake of
time, but we did evaluate in a multivariate analysis
other covariates that were potentially associated with overall
survival to evaluate for potential confounders, asking the question whether
these antibiotic exposures were suggestive of sicker patients
getting antibiotics and doing worse, versus suggestive of a microbiome
phenotype. And when we analyzed these various covariates, and you can see that
in the paper, we did see that
PIM exposure was an independent
predictor of decreased overall survival, as was
pre-lymphodepletion lactate dehydrogenase or LDH, as well as a
worse performance status by ECOG.
So in that multivariate analysis, this
PIM exposure was associated and held up in terms of decreased
progression-free and overall survival.
And I'll also talk to you a little bit about other antibiotics that patients were
exposed to that didn't decrease overall and progression-free survival, just to kind
of round out that it's not just antibiotics
given to the patients in the weeks prior to CAR T-cell therapy, but what the
actual antibiotics target.
So delving into that a little bit more, there was a subsequent paper
from a multicenter cohort, investigators in Germany at three centers,
Moffitt and MD Anderson Cancer Center, of which Dr.
Jank was a part of this, leading the study, and they evaluated a
cohort of patients looking at no antibiotics,
low risk antibiotics, and high risk antibiotics.
And here you can see this yellow line.
Again, they saw that patients exposed to high risk antibiotics, as noted here,
piperacillin-tazobactam, meropenem, ceftazidime, and cefepime,
had the lowest proportion of surviving.
A subsequent study also delved into, in a multicenter
cohort, no or low risk antibiotics, cephalosporins, and PIM.
And again, PIM still had the worst
progression-free survival.
And then finally, this study broadened PIM.
So PIM was a subset of antibiotics that we were looking at
that target obligate anaerobes. And here in this study, they broadened
not only all cephalosporins, but also a more broad
definition, as you can see here, of anaerobic antibiotics.
And again, in this analysis, anaerobic antibiotic-exposed
patients, again, in this case, six weeks prior to CAR
T-cell therapy, still did the worst compared to the other
subgroups. So again, I just want to go back to thinking about
this antibiotic exposure, what the progression-free survival and overall survival
is showing us. It's not just antibiotic exposure during this time
period, but what bacteria are being targeted by those antibiotics, which
is associated with these differential outcomes.
In another study looking at patients who received anti-BCMA-targeted
CAR T-cell therapy for multiple myeloma, again, any
antibiotic exposure was associated with decreased progression-free survival.
Cephalosporins were associated with decreased progression-free survival
and fluoroquinolones as well. You can see the P values
for their various analyses. But this is the only study to date that has looked at
patients who had multiple myeloma.So in summary,
antibiotic exposure and CAR T cell therapy has been investigated
in these five independent studies.
You can see the references here, all of them evaluating anti-CD19
CAR T cell therapy except one. They've been
investigated in both the US and other international
centers, including Germany, Spain, and China.
The sample sizes, and then the antibiotic window I want to draw your attention
to. All of these studies have focused on the pre-CAR T cell window with
differential time periods. And then in terms of antibiotics,
they've been linked with worse survival across several
different antibiotic sub classifications.
And in two studies, antibiotic exposure has been associated with
increased risk of immune effector cell-associated
neurotoxicity syndrome, or ICANS.
There was a subsequent study that also evaluated ICANS, but found it to not be
significant.
So in summary, anaerobic antibiotics
may influence CAR T cell therapy by altering the intestinal microbiome.
We hypothesize that these antibiotics
lead to a more unfavorable microbiome constituents
within the
gut, and that has been associated with decreased antitumor
activity and increased toxicity.
Which really, now that we have these strong associations and phenomenology,
is very critical to investigate this in
randomized studies, but also in preclinical models so that we can understand
regulatory mechanisms.
So before I delve into that, I did want to highlight
overlapping bacterial taxa that have been identified in the CD19 targeted
CAR T cell studies. These studies have, as you saw, have been
evaluated across different locales, different environmental factors, dietary
factors, but there have been some bacterial taxa that have
emerged across the various studies.
And what I'm showing you here in this summary table are taxa that have been
identified in terms of their association with CAR T cell outcomes in at
least two separate publications.
So here's the taxa,
the genus level species, and then their association in terms of
outcomes. So you can see Ruminococcus, two different species that have been
identified, and their association with the outcomes.
And so I think that one real key area of
interest from the data summarized here is that we can now
evaluate these
in preclinical models and understand mechanistically what these bacterial taxa
are doing. One that will come up in some of the subsequent slides is
Akkermansia, which is also already been shown in preclinical studies to
be associated with CAR T cell outcomes.
So we will delve into this a little bit more.
So in terms of the first preclinical evidence that I want to show you, this
study is one in immunocompetent mouse model, where mice were
infused with A20, a CD19 expressing lymphoma at day minus
22. They were then exposed to meropenem from
day minus seven to day minus three, cyclophosphamide for
lymphodepletion, and then administered CAR T cell therapy.
These tumors were infused subcutaneously, so they were
measuring the tumor volume. And what you can see is that those
mice that had meropenem exposure with the CAR T, they
had more outgrowth of tumor compared to better control in the
vehicle treated CAR T cell treated mice.
Here, in panel H, the investigators did show the survival of the
non-CAR T cell groups. There was no difference.
But in the CAR T cell groups, the survival was much lower,
significantly lower in the meropenem treated mice.
And in another study, investigators evaluated fecal microbiota
transplant
from responders and non-responders of CD19 CAR T cell therapy, again, in a
balanced immunocompetent model.
They gave antibiotic depletion, FMT, and then
A20 tumor as well, as well as cyclophosphamide
and CAR T cell therapy. And what they found was that
those mice that received responder FMT did
have improved survival compared to those that received
non-responder FMT. Again, suggesting that the constituents within the
microbiome were playing a role in this response.
One of the factors that we are actively investigating
in its role in CAR T cell responses and in the microbiome research
in general, are microbial derived
metabolites, so the metabolites the bacteria secrete
into their microenvironment.
Many metabolites have been identified
for their role in CAR T cell therapy.
So here's a summary of a figure looking at non-genetically modified cellular
therapies and the associated metabolites, and genetically
modified cellular therapies such as TCRT and CAR T, and the metabolites that
have been associated with them. And I'll show some of the data here.
So one of our questions is, are microbiota derived metabolites
involved in regulating CAR T cell function?
We performed a preclinical in vitro study where we
looked at Akkermansia. Again, we had that list of various bacteria, and we looked
at several of these bacteria in in vitro culture before validating them in
our in vivo models. And here's an example of an Akkermansia
muciniphila supernatant, which essentially we grew up the
Akkermansia muciniphila. We looked at the supernatant at various
concentrations and performed killing assay at various effector
to target ratios. And what we found was that supernatant from the
Akkermansia was associated with improved killing in our in vitro
assays and better tumor control. This
dovetails really nicely and beautifully with a paper that was recently published,
that shows that Akkermansia species is
involved in
controlling tumor in
mice that received CD19 CAR T cell therapy.
So in this model, they used C57 black 6 mice
that had aCD19 expressing
tumor. They were inoculated with a CD19 expressing tumor, CAR T cells, and then the
organs were harvested. But also the mice were gavaged with Akkermansia
species 2261. What they found was that in those
mice that were recipients of the Akkermansia, there was better tumor control.
Again, the tumor was measured longitudinally over time, and
survival was prolonged in the Akkermansia recipients.
When they delved into this further, they
evaluated the various metabolites in those recipients.
They saw that the Akkermansia recipients were secreting indole-3-acetic
acid. And again, at day 13,
using some AhR knockout mice, they saw that it was dependent on the AhR
axis, this role of Akkermansia, this Akkermansia species was
dependent on the AhR axis. So again, really
interesting data beginning to identify mechanistic
insights in terms of how these bacteria, the AhR
axis, are modulating CAR T cell therapy.
Another study looked at succinate.
So they co-cultured CAR T cells with succinate and
found that succinate was associated with more of an
oxidative phosphorylation phenotype.
We know in the CAR T cell literature that not only subsets of
CAR T cells, but also the metabolic profile of the CAR T cells
plays an important role in the activity and persistence of the CAR T
cells. So they found that succinate was associated with more of
oxidative phosphorylation phenotype.
And then these CAR T cells were administered to mice, and
they found, again, that the mice that were
treated with a fructooligosaccharide diet,
this was a prebiotic fiber that's fermented in the gut and significantly
produces succinate, that those mice on that diet, compared to the
control
diet, had much better tumor control
of a myeloma cell line, ARP1.
Finally, in terms of metabolites, I do want to highlight literature
from a publication several years ago now from the group of Crystal
Makel, where they evaluated CAR T cell
culture media using inosine as compared to
their standard control media and did find that inosine, which is
also largely produced by the microbiome, that it was
associated with improved stemness and
more of a naive central memory subset of the
CAR T cells. They also found that these CAR T cells that were
cultured in inosine had better tumor control in in vivo assays.
And this is further being evaluated in the GMP setting.
And then the final paper, again, I wanted to give you the breadth of this
literature, although this field is still quite early.
The final publication that's looked at preclinical evidence of CAR T cell
therapy and the intestinal microbiome was one where mice,
again, an immunocompetent model using A20, were administered
vancomycin ad libitum.
The investigators found that those recipients that
received CAR T and vancomycin had
better tumor control,
and that was both in A20 and B16. B16 melanoma
model that was expressing CD19.
And then they also investigated various
aspects of the
tumor microenvironment and did see that there was increased antigen
presentation of the tumor antigen in the
CAR T vancomycin-treated mice compared to the
control.
So in summary, just to be quite brief, exposure to anaerobic
antibiotics prior to CAR T cell therapy is associated with shorter
progression-free survival and overall survival.
And several studies have also identified that this antibiotic
exposure is associated with increased incidence of immune effector cell-associated
neurotoxicity syndrome. Clinical cohorts demonstrate that specific
bacterial species may enhance CAR T cell outcomes.
However, preclinical models are needed to understand the mechanisms by
which the microbiome modulates these clinical outcomes.
And as you saw during this talk, there are several independent
groups that have validated in distinct preclinical
models that the microbiome is having a mechanistic
role in these outcomes. With that, I would like to acknowledge my
lab and funding sources, and I'm available for questions. Thank you so much.
Thank you for the talk.
My question is, how does fecal microbiome
transplantation
work in clinical setting?
In the clinical setting?
So you're just asking how is it administered or how does it work mechanistically?
Which specifically?
How will it be administered? How does it work, just general.
Oh, yes. So, there are various fecal
microbiota transplant, or FMT studies.
So many of them have capsules
or different routes of administration of the FMT.
They can also, depending upon the context, be administered orally
or per rectum. And these are consortia
of bacteria from responders and non-responders.
Another active area of investigation in the field, as opposed to giving a bulk
fecal microbiota transplant, is to use some of these
retrospective studies and preclinical studies to develop insights as
to the specific bacteria that are relevant for a
given clinical condition and to identify those
bacteria and administer them as a consortia of
bacteria. So not a bulk FMT from a patient or from a
healthy donor, but to give specific consortia.
And I think you're going to hear about that a little bit more in subsequent
presentations. Thank you.
Question over at the other microphone.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Great talk. Thanks so much. I was curious, in your Akkermansia data, if
you quantified the amount. As you may have seen from solid
tumors, there seems to be a sweet spot, and too much is also
bad.
Yes. And it's so interesting you say that, because in our initial
analysis of Akkermansia from the publication,
Akkermansia
seemed to have an association with worse outcomes.
But yes, in our in vitro studies, we did quantify the amount
of Akkermansia. You saw that we also looked at different concentrations of the
Akkermansia supernatant and found a sweet spot which was most beneficial.
So we did quantify and keep it consistent across all those assays, and we do
that in all of those in vitro studies looking at the bacterial taxa.
Hi, Melody. Jennifer McQuaid. Beautiful talk.
So, in terms of the antibiotics, and deleterious
effects on CAR T, you of course showed the
preclinical models to kind of establish causality.
You also mentioned that randomized control trials would
be nice. How would you conceptualize doing an RCT of
that?
Yeah. So I think that with all of these
independent retrospective studies, a randomized control trial would be
really nice to do. For example, we have enough data to suggest
that evaluating randomization for pip-tazo
versus cefepime in the setting of neutropenic fever would be
relevant.
I think the biggest limiting factor is cost to be able to do those
studies.
We have not done that yet at my center, and I know that
if there were funding for such a study to be able to follow that over time,
that would be quite interesting. I do want to make a plug, though.
There is a randomized study that was done at Memorial
Sloan Kettering that is evaluating pip-tazo and
cefepime in the setting of allogeneic transplant.
So really similar insights there, but looking in the context of
transplant GvHD and various outcomes.
And I believe that study will be really interesting for us to
understand and perhaps extrapolate insights until we have
the opportunity to do a randomized study in this instance.
Yeah.
Yeah. No, that would be the gold standard, and that would be very important to do.
I wonder if PCORI might actually be a mechanism for
that.
For the randomization for funding?
Yeah.
Perhaps. Yeah. No, I've actually looked into some of the PCORI funding.
I don't know all the logistics of what you need, but I know there's a certain bar
for PCORI.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Thank you.
Hi, Melody. Faiza Shaikh here.
Hi.
Not sure if you can see me, but, I had very much the same question as Dr.
McQuaid over there. And I guess, as a follow-up to that,
do people on the clinical side, when we're treating patients in the hospital,
are we actually seeing some of these findings from the antibiotic
microbiome data actually penetrate into clinical
decision-making?
Do you have any insight on that?
Yes. So yeah. I think that at my institution at
Stanford, based on all of this independent data from the retrospective studies,
we now give cefepime as our frontline if a patient has
CRS as opposed to pip-tazo, and we escalate if needed, given
concern for bacteremia or toxic
presentation. So we have made those changes because I think this data
is compelling enough. But I completely agree with the question that a
randomized study would make us all much more inclined to
use this data for our clinical treatment and management. Yeah.
Wonderful. Beautiful work. Thank you.
Thank you.
Melody, very nice talk. I was curious about the
kinetics of the recovery of the gut dysbiosis in those
patients post antibiotics and post
conditioning regimen. Did you look at the T cell fitness,
the CAR T cell fitness, as a function of the recovery?
How long does it take in your study?
In Paris, with Camille Bigenwald, it took more than
two months or three months, and 25% of patients
never recovered. So I'm just curious about the fractions
of patients that will never recover from these conditioning regimens and
antibiotics administration.
Yes, no, great question. I didn't show any of our longitudinal data.
So we follow the fecal microbiota of our
patients at Stanford through day 90, and we find that
at around four weeks, once patients are discharged from the hospital,
off antibiotics, starting to likely resume more of their diet, we
don't capture dietary information, we start to see that the microbiome
is coming back toward the baseline.
But it's not until about that three-month timeframe that we do start to see
it pretty close to the baseline. It does have a pretty similar recovery back to the
baseline, but it takes several months, as you mentioned.
And so we're looking at those kinetics, and we're also looking at that in
conjunction with CAR T cell persistence and subsets of CAR T cells.
So we have that data that we're analyzing. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you, Melody. That was fantastic.
Are my slides going to come up?
Yes, here they are. Okay.
So,
I'm at City of Hope, and the title of my talk is, "CAR
T Response Rates: How to Harness the Microbiome."
Here are my disclosures.
So some of the slides that Melody showed, I'm going to rehash,
hopefully not too much. But this is data from Melody's
paper that really, I think, set the stage for the
association of antibiotic exposures and reduced CAR T cell
outcomes. And we embarked on a similar study about a
year laterAs Melody stated, this is a
multi-institutional and national consortium.
We had patients from Germany,
MD Anderson, and Moffitt. And what we found was
very similar to what Melody
and Marcel and Marco found,
that antibiotic exposures was associated with reduced progression-free
survival. This was reproduced in the US
patients as well as the German patients.
And then this translated into
reduced overall survival.
Interestingly, there was this signal that we could see in terms of progression
incidence. So it was not just toxicities, it wasn't just patients
not doing well and dying from other outcomes, but really
the lymphoma
not responding or coming back.
We were able to examine a variety of different
antibiotics and
we found that pip/tazo signal was there,
meropenem signal was there. Meropenem and imipenem, I
think a lot of clinicians in the audience know that imipenem has been supplanted by
meropenem
due to, I think, pharmaceutical availability.
We did see that some of these less harmful antibiotics, cefepime
and ceftazidime,
even though they're microbiome sparing, they were also associated with
poor responses, at least in this study.
It should be said that these antibiotic associations were heavily
confounded. So the patients here that receive
these bad antibiotics are in yellow, and I'm
showing you that they have higher serum LDH levels, which is
a common surrogate for lymphoma burden.
And then we actually quantified this in the patients that had PET
scan metabolic volumes available.
So these patients that were getting these antibiotics were
coming in with more lymphoma. And so this is a
retrospective study. It's interesting, it's hypothesis generating, but it is
confounded.
We got at this a little bit by subsetting the
patients by LDH values. So here I'm showing
you the data by tertiles. The patients were divided into
three tertiles based on LDH values.
And this antibiotic association seems to hold up across all
three tertiles. It's not perfect, but at least suggests that we're
studying a phenomenon that is not purely driven by this confounding effect
of sicker patients getting antibiotics.
And then, as Melody showed earlier,
a murine model is a nice way of potentially getting at
causality. And so Rishika in my group did the
study that was published in "Blood" in 2024.
She found that pre-treating mice with meropenem led to
reduced CAR T-cell efficacy.
So, what are potential mechanisms?
So in my talk, I'll try to get at two potential mechanisms.
And it's still relatively early days, but I think we do have some
interesting leads. And so one of the mechanisms has to
do with what I think Howard is going to talk about
later which is enterococcus, and how
enterococcus can function as a
booster of the immune response, especially in the setting of antibiotic
exposures.
So what I'm showing you here is a genetic
pathway
in the bacterial samples that's associated with
peptidoglycan
biosynthesis. So this is an antibiotic resistance pathway.
And what we found was that this pathway was highly enriched in the patients
that received high-risk antibiotics, as I'm showing you here.
And then it also stratified nicely for progression in these patients.
The finding on the left I thought made sense, right?
The patients that received antibiotics have enrichment
for antibiotic resistance. So that makes sense, right?
The antibiotic exposure's probably selected for these antibiotic resistant
bacteria. On the right, what I'm showing you is
that the patients that had high abundances of these
resistant bacteria, they actually were doing better with a lower
progression incidence. And this, at first, was surprising to me,
because I thought that these are antibiotic resistance
genes. They are associated with antibiotic exposures, but then these patients are
somehow doing better. So it didn't really jive with our
overall story.
But when we looked into it a little bit further,
it turns out this pathway is attributed to E.
faecium, and these
patients are colonized with vancomycin-resistant E.
faecium reverie.
And if you take a look at these two risk factors that we've identified in
combination, you start to see an interesting pattern.
So in the red line here, are patients who have
two poor risk factors. So they received these high-risk
antibiotics prior to CAR T-cell therapy, and they were also missing
this genetic pathway for resistance.
So these patients are doing very poorly.
They have essentially 100% progression incidence rate.
On the other hand, there are some patients that have both factors in their favor,
so they were able to avoid these high-risk antibiotics prior to CAR T-cell therapy,
and they were also harboring these antibiotic resistant bacteria.
And they're in the blue line, and they're doing very well.
Almost three quarters of them are essentially cured in terms of their
lymphoma. And then the patients with an
intermediate risk factor, just missing one or the other,
those patients have this in between phenotype.
So what we think is happening, and I
always feel awkward showing data... produced by other people in front of them.
So this is Howard's data.
But this is a summary showing that E.
faecium expresses this enzyme called SagA, and
SagA functions to break down peptidoglycans in the cell wall into
these fragments called muramyl dipeptides, and these can function as NOD2
ligands and activate the innate immune system.
So this is some more of Howard's data.
It turns out that in mice that are treated with
immunotherapy with PD-1 blockade, they need to have
NOD2 intact in order to respond. If the mice are
NOD2 deficient, they don't respond to immunotherapy.
And then on the right is a model where they're rescuing mice
that are antibiotic treated. And so if the mice are treated or rescued
with a wild-type strain of E. faecium, they respond nicely to PD-1
blockade. However, if they are
rescued with a SagA-deficient strain, then those mice fail to
respond to PD-1 therapy.
So we wanted to see if this phenomenon, which was in the setting of checkpoint
inhibitors, could potentially be holding up in the setting of CAR T cell therapy,
and we have some hints that this might be the case.
So these are blood levels of muramyl dipeptides that can
be quantified by mass spec, and we found that
complete responder patients have higher levels of muramyl dipeptides
compared to non-responder patients, and this actually stratifies for
progression-free survival.
The next mechanism that I wanted to get at is Akkermansia, which we heard about
earlier, and this is a very nice paper from the group
of Laurence Zivkovic, who's in the audience and sitting in the front row.
So again, I'm presenting data to the person who produced the data.
This is a study in 58 patients.
Most of the patients were B-cell lymphoma patients, and most of the patients
received CAR T cells that were
CD28 costimulatory CAR T
cells. This was one of the interesting findings, which
was that Akkermansia muciniphila
was highly associated with improved response rate.
And this, as Melody pointed out earlier, this was
corroborated by our earlier study in that
multi-center study with German and US patients.
So Akkermansia seems to be reproducibly associated
with good CAR T cell outcomes.
Here's some more data from Laurence's study.
In a mouse model, introducing Akkermansia led to
better CAR T cell responses in the mice and increased
CAR T cells in the marrow and in the tumor.
So this
is reminiscent of an earlier study from Laurence.
So this issue of "Science" from 2018, where three different groups
found that PD-1 blockade in patients was associated with
microbiome composition. And one of the
findings from Laurence's study is that Akkermansia was, again,
a good bacteria and associated with improved PD-1
response.
So we wanted to try to get at this in a mouse model of
checkpoint inhibitor blockade. And so my group has
been interested in Akkermansia for different reasons.
Akkermansia is a mucus-degrading bacteria and
is found in both humans and in mice and is associated with neutropenic
fever in bone marrow transplant patients.
So in that setting, it seems to be not necessarily a good bug, but maybe a
bad bug.
But in that study from a few years back, we used a
strategy that Greg Barton
identified with tetracycline treatment.
So you can treat the mice in the drinking water with tetracycline for three weeks.
This will eradicate the endogenous Akkermansia in the mice,
as well as some other bacteria, but it's fairly narrow in terms of its
activity. And then you can see what happens to those mice.
You can also reintroduce the Akkermansia into the mice and see what happens
in terms of the mouse phenotype. And so here I'm showing you that the tetracycline
works really well. The endogenous Akkermansia that you can see in the
non-tetracycline-treated patients is gone.
And then we can reintroduce Akkermansia, and if anything,
it achieves even higher abundances in that setting.
So we've started studying this in a melanoma model.
This is B16-F10, where mice are treated with
CTLA-4 blockade. And so I'll just walk you through these
curves.
In red are the mice succumbing to melanoma without any other treatment.
And then in blue, I'm showing you that tetracycline doesn't really affect that
normal curve. In green are the mice receiving
CTLA-4 therapy, and they get a nice benefit from the
checkpoint inhibition with a delay in terms of the melanoma outgrowth.
Interestingly,
and surprising to me, tetracycline treatment had no effect.
And so I thought that tetracycline, which was going to get rid of the
Akkermansia, could have an abrogation of
this benefit from CTLA-4, but it seems to be almost superimposable, the
benefit.
However, if we introduced Akkermansia back into the mice after
tetracycline treatment, then we saw this pretty dramatic
augmentation of CTLA-4 benefit in these mice.
So this was, we thought, pretty interesting.
Here are the survival curves from the same experiments combined.
And we've also started to test this with PD-1 blockade as well.
So here is PD-1 blockade not being impacted by
tetracycline treatment. And then,
however, if we pretreat with tetracycline and then introduce
Akkermansia back, then we see this augmentation of PD-1
blockade response comparing the orange line with the black line.
Like I said, it's still pretty early days in terms of what's happening,
butWe do see that this treatment,
tetracycline plus Akkermansia Advac, leads to increased
CD8 T cell infiltration in the tumors.
There doesn't really seem to be any effect on CD4s or regulatory T cells.
And we also see greater CD8 T cell
activation in the tumor, so higher expression of PD-1,
TIM-3, LAG-3, TIGIT, and ICOS.
This session is about cell therapy, CAR T cell
therapy. Is there any evidence that Akkermansia could
augment
cell therapy in a mouse model? So we started to get at this with
overexpressing OVA antigens in Akkermansia.
This is in collaboration with Lauren Davey, who is an Akkermansia
microbiologist at University of Victoria and is an expert on this.
And so in collaboration with her, she expressed
these mini genes that express the class I antigen
and the class II antigen.
And so we've tested this in the CTLA-4 model, which I'm showing you on top,
and we see that this OVA overexpressing
Akkermansia actually leads to further augmentation
over the wild-type Akkermansia strain, and this also helps to
augment responses to T cell therapy,
OVA specific T cell therapy at least.
And so we're very interested in seeing what are the effects of
Akkermansia in a CAR T cell model in mice.
In terms of potential mechanisms, it's still fairly early
days. On the Akkermansia side, we're able to get at
the genetics of Akkermansia by utilizing mutants.
So here, Lauren is sharing with us this strain of
Akkermansia 0166. It's a strain that she generated
with a transposon that is deficient in a pillin
gene. This is not Akkermansia, but Akkermansia
expresses these finger-like projections that help
to bring in mucus and internalize the mucus and consume the
mucus. If you knock out this pillin gene, then the Akkermansia can't
do this anymore. And if we introduce this strain
of Akkermansia,
you get the orange line here. So there is no augmentation of CTLA-4
response, as opposed to the purple line, which is the wild-type strain.
So pillin expression seems to be important.
The other thing that seems to be important is
the other bacteria. So the rest of the microbiome also seems to be critically
important as well.
So
when we treat mice with tetracycline, we lose the
Akkermansia, which is in light green here.
So on the left are mice that are not treated with tetracycline.
They have Akkermansia present. On the right, the Akkermansia is gone.
But there are other bacteria that are picked off by the tetracycline treatment as
well. And it varies a little bit from experiment to experiment because the
microbiome of the mice is variable between shipments.
But we tend to usually see loss of
Sangariabacter,
Fusomonas, and Dubosella as well after the
tetracycline therapy. And so we think that these other
microbiome members probably function to inhibit
Akkermansia and keep it from
mediating its full beneficial phenotype.
And so we've gotten at that hypothesis a little bit.
We
can either treat with a fecal transplant that came
from a mouse that was not tetracycline treated, or we
can use a
cultivated
fecal transplant, or we can use a consortium which includes those
bacteria that were also picked off by tetracycline that I just showed you earlier.
And so what I'm showing you here is that
in the mice that receive tetracycline and CTLA-4
blockade, you get the
red line here. If you treat these mice with
or you reintroduce wild-type Akkermansia just by itself, you see that nice
benefit that we usually see. And then you see reversion of that
benefit with either the FMT
from naive mice completely, or you can also see a
partial reversion with a consortium.
So
it's a little bit complicated, but what we think is happening is that
these tetracycline-sensitive bacteria are somehow
harming the
full beneficial effect of the Akkermansia.
So here's a model of what we think is going on.
Above, we have the setting of a
cancer patient who has Akkermansia in his microbiome,
but the microbiome is otherwise intact.
And so in this setting, the Akkermansia, even if it's present, is probably
inhibited. We know that it's inhibited by metabolites
such as propionate. And so
Akkermansia is at a low abundance.
It's not chewing up the mucus like it can do potentially.
And anti-tumor immunity is not as strong as it could be.
However, if we in a targeted manner manipulate the
microbiome of the mice, we cause some damage,
pick off some of these commensal members, and then, if
necessary, reintroduce the Akkermansia, then you've depleted some of these
metabolites that inhibit Akkermansia, and Akkermansia can
increase in terms of abundance. It can upregulate mucus-degrading
bacteria. And then this will presumably weaken
the gut barrier in the colon and allow translocation of
bacterial-derived products to augment
checkpoint inhibitor therapy or CAR T cell inhibitor therapy.
So
in terms of
randomized clinical trials,
Dr. McQuoid asked that great question earlier.
So at MD AndersonWhile I was still there, I
was involved in establishing this trial led by Neeraj
Sainani and Jason Weston. So FMT is
being collected actually from CAR T cell responders
patients, and then introduced to patients that we think are not going
to do well with CAR T due to antibiotic exposures.
That was the initial design. My understanding is that it was maybe a little
bit too complicated, and the enrollment
was too strict and was slow. And so I think they've since pivoted
to multiple myeloma patients and to
not having that antibiotic exposure requirement.
But I think with that new version, the study is occurring quite well.
I've since moved to City of Hope, and there we
collaborated with
Alex Khoruts at University of Minnesota.
So here we're collecting
fecal capsules that are
collected from healthy Minnesotans who have avoided antibiotic exposures.
And we wanted to
treat at three different time points.
So patients are getting a fecal transplant prior to
leukapheresis in the hopes that this could potentially improve the T
cell functionality of the T cells that you're collecting from the
patients that are then manufactured into CAR T cells.
We also treat again prior to CAR T cell infusion, and then we treat
again later after neutrophil recovery.
So we're kind of trying to cover our bases.
This is enrolling reasonably well.
I think we're at patient number four currently.
So with that, I'd like to acknowledge my collaborators
and sources of funding, and then I definitely need to
acknowledge Rishika and
Steven, who did the work that I presented today. Thank you.
Question to the right.
Great talk. Thank you so much.
There are papers that talk about certain
species of bacteria which are supposed to be in your
colon, but when they are present orally, they cause
trouble, like different types of cancers.
Could that be an issue with fecal
transplantation
in future?
Yeah, that's an interesting question.
I'm actually more familiar with the reverse concept, where if you
find oral bacteria, typically oral bacteria, and they're
very abundant in your fecal specimens, that could be a bad sign, a sign
of dysbiosis.
We're hoping to try to avoid that in the FMT studies by
utilizing these healthy volunteers who
have not had any exposure to antibiotics and are
phenotypically healthy.
I don't think we actually profile them for a particular
microbiome composition in terms of selection.
But in general, they tend not to have domination by these oral
bacteria.
Over here.
Super interesting talk, Rob.
So it seems like the Akkermansia is doing something a bit different
before these mice are treated with tetracycline than when it's
reintroduced, right? And I guess it may not be
the same strains of Akkermansia either.
So have you thought about doing genomic or functional profiling,
metagenomic, metatranscriptomics of Akkermansia before and after?
Yeah. No, that's exactly right. So we are planning experiments
where we profile the gene expression of Akkermansia in
the different settings of tetracycline pretreatment
versus not, or introducing the inhibitory
bacteria or not. I think that'll be very interesting to see how Akkermansia is
behaving differently. And then we are also
testing the various
substrains or species of Akkermansia.
So there's muciniphila, there's
muciliensis, there's byeonsis. And so
we're going to test all of these systematically in our mouse model.
Very cool. One other question. I noticed you see several
other species aside from Akkermansia disappear after
tetracycline treatment, but you also see a bloom of other taxa.
So I noticed Hungatella and some others came up.
Maybe your thoughts on how Akkermansia might be interacting with those
new blooms of bugs?
That's a good question, too. I think to get at that, we would probably have to
use either broader antibiotics or maybe
turn to gnotobiotic experiments and see if, does Akkermansia need any
help from partners, any beneficial partners?
I think that's a very open question that we haven't really gotten at yet.
Thanks.
Related to that question, do you see a change in
fungi with tetracycline treatment?
I didn't see if you were evaluating the communities using
metagenomics and stuff like that, so it would be included or if it
was 16S based.
Yeah. So that's a great question. The honest answer is we haven't really looked
very carefully at the effects on fungi.
If I had to
guess, I would say that probably the fungi are not expanding
too much because the tetracycline is fairly narrow in terms of
its spectrum of activity. So the other bacteria are probably more
likely filling that space versus fungi, but I don't know for sure.
We should definitely look.
Yeah. Excellent talk. Thank you. And this goes to everybody, I guess.
So the antibiotics also hit things like macrophages.
Have you looked at what the macrophage component are
in the responder versus non-responder mouse models or humans?
So we haven't specifically looked at macrophages.
We have looked at the myeloid cells within the tumors,
and there we do see
increased classical DC1s, CDC1s in the setting
of tetracycline and Akkermansia add back.
We don't really know why that would be the case.
Hmm.
There hasn't been anything obvious in terms of
inhibitory macrophages. The other thing I would say is
that the antibiotic manipulation and microbiome
manipulation that we do,
it's pretty early in the model. So there's three
weeks of tetracycline, and then it's discontinued.
So there's no longer any antibiotics being
treated into the mice.
Okay. Thank you.
Rob, one quick question. So for the pili, have you
profiled any bacterial protein expression on the
pili, and why the absence of them might mitigate
the role of the Akkermansia in your mouse model?
I think the pili is an interesting finding.
But it's a little bit of a blunt tool.
So I think that these Akkermansia, they
utilize the pili to bring in the mucin.
So the pili-deficient mutants are kind
of mucolytic insufficient. And so they're
really handicapped. They're not doing very well.
They do colonize, but they don't seem to mediate the benefit.
Okay. Well, thank you. And then our last speaker,
Howard Hang
from Scripps University.
Thank you, everyone. I just want to thank Rob for inviting me to participate in
this session to share some of the work we've been doing in the microbiome area.
And I've been really privileged to follow two excellent talks to really
set the stage for what we do in my laboratory.
So I'm just down the road here at Scripps, so if you guys get a chance to, when
you're in San Diego, please come visit us.
But my lab has been interested in how the microbiota modulates immune
responses, but also cancer immunotherapy.
And it's always great to borrow this slide from Laurence to articulate this
point that not only do the bacteria modulate the immune response, but they modulate
a variety of cancer therapies as well.
So you guys are all familiar with these three famous papers that Rob already
mentioned that highlight the role of the microbiota in checkpoint therapy
response. And more recently, there's been a couple of small clinical trials
that suggest that FMT into patients can also promote
or augment tumor growth in patients.
And I think this highlights a challenging and unique opportunity for
modulating microbiota composition and activity to really predictably
enhance immunotherapy. Okay. So I
think we got interested a few years ago of wondering, are there specific bacterial
species that promote checkpoint therapy?
And my lab had already been working on Enterococcus for other reasons in the gut.
And we're sort of
caught our attention to see that some patients that respond better to checkpoint
therapy were enriched in Enterococcus faecium.
And this appeared to be across multiple studies in the early studies of checkpoint
blockade.
So we simply asked the question is, does Enterococcus faecium, as Rob
already alluded to,
promote checkpoint therapy in mouse models?
And let me just give you a little bit more background on Enterococcus.
So these are actually quite prevalent bacteria in the human population.
There's over 70 species that are identified in the environment in other animals,
but in humans, really faecalis and faecium are the most prominent.
These are gram-positive bacteria
that actually are quite tolerant to a variety of cellular stresses and
antibiotics. So you'll often see that, and you guys as clinicians know that
vancomycin-resistant Enterococcus are really problematic in the hospital setting.
But historically, there's also been observations that Enterococcus could be
probiotic or beneficial. And so actually in the United States, some of you might
actually give your pets 404 in which the major ingredient is actually Enterococcus
faecium. And in Europe, you can actually buy over the counter
this dietary supplement where the Enterococcus strain is from a
Swedish infant isolated many decades ago. Okay.
So at the time we got into this study, the role of immune modulation by
Enterococcus wasn't really well described, and we thought it was quite interesting
to follow this up further. And this was really started from an exploratory study
that we did when I was at Rockefeller by a very adventurous graduate student,
Kavita Rangan, where we used C. elegans as a very simple animal model to
explore beneficial or pathogenic bacteria.
And through a variety of assays, she compared the role of Enterococcus faecium
versus faecalis in C. elegans. And through a series of activity-driven
assays, she isolated a secreted enzyme that was annotated as screening
engin A. This is a cell wall remodeling enzyme that's important for bacterial cell
division and peptidoglycan cleavage.
But she showed that Enterococcus produces SagA at quite high
levels and that SagA was sufficient to promote immunity in C.
elegans by maybe a totally different mechanism than it does in mammals.
But at that time, it led us to a new activity that we didn't appreciate before in
Enterococcus.
And subsequent to that work, we went on to characterize the biochemical activity of
SagA. This is the X-ray crystal structure of its active site domain.
It's a peptidase that cleaves murmur peptides that are crossing into smaller
pieces. And you can see in the middle panel an HPLC trace where we
took purified crossing peptidoglycan.
And with the incubation of SagA in a time-dependent manner, generates these two
smaller fragments. And in the literature, it was already known that these smaller
murmur peptides were known to activate and promote the activity of
NOD2, an intracellular pattern recognition receptor for peptidoglycan.
And we showed that purified fragments from the SagA reaction stimulate NOD2
in cell lines and proposed a very simple model for which the
expression of SagA in bacteria could generate small
NOD2 active murmur peptides to promote immune responses, potentially in myeloid
cells.
Okay. So to further characterize that, we went on to evaluate this in a variety of
animal models further, but I just want to summarize our early work where initially
we discovered that Enterococcus could promote gut immunity, likely through NOD2
expression in myeloid cells, monocytes, or DCs, and that
promoted intestinal immunity to intestinal infections such as Salmonella or C.
diff.But with the discovery of Enterococcus in checkpoint therapy
responsive patients, we started asking whether Enterococcus and SagA were
sufficient to promote checkpoint therapy in mouse models further. Okay.
So to give you a little bit of data from this paper a few years ago, Matt Griffin,
a former postdoc in my laboratory, set up a very simple model in the
laboratory. Just take B16 mice, give them antibiotics, and then we could orally
administer the Enterococcus from the drinking water,
and then challenge them with a tumor and give them checkpoint blockade.
And what Matt found is when we give these mice
Enterococcus faecium, we see that it nicely synergizes with checkpoint therapy in
this antibiotic treatment model, whereas Enterococcus faecalis does not do that.
Okay? And importantly, we were fortunate to generate a SagA knock-in
strain where we express SagA in the chromosome of faecalis, and you can see that
SagA expression in faecalis alone was sufficient to promote
anti-tumor activity of checkpoint blockade with CTLA-4 and with
PD-L1. Okay, so we were quite excited to see that, in this
setting, that faecium was sufficient to promote checkpoint therapy and reduce the
growth of tumors.
Okay, so with regard to its potential immune mechanism of action, these are
a few pieces of data from Matt's paper where when we looked at immune profiling of
the tumor-infiltrated lymphocytes.
What we noticed is that we didn't see any changes in regular T cells, as you can
see in the left panel. But what we did notice is that increased numbers of CD8 T
cells in the tumor and also increased numbers of activated CD8 T cells with
increased granzyme B expression.
And when we looked at antigen-specific responses, we see increased tumor specific
responses. When we give mice
faecium that express the SagA compared to Enterococcus faecium alone, which is
inactive at promoting tumor clearance.
Excuse me.
I showed you before in that graphic that we thought that the mechanism of action
was going through NOD2. So one key experiment was when we do these same experiments
in NOD2 knockout mice, you can see that the activity of SagA-expressing bacteria,
in this case Enterococcus faecium, was totally abrogated in NOD2 knockout mice.
And actually, Rob, we didn't coordinate this, but Rob showed you already that SagA
knockout in faecium already in the original bacterium was also
lost when we deleted SagA in Enterococcus faecium. Okay.
All right. So that led us to this idea that
cell wall fragments from key bacteria such as Enterococcus can promote
immunotherapy in vivo. All these experiments we did were in antibiotic-treated
mice, so they're sort of in principle mono-colonized, right?
So we asked the question, what happens in microbiota-intact mice that are maybe
less active? And we took advantage of this observation that mice you get from
Taconic Labs versus Jackson Labs have differential responses to checkpoint therapy,
and this was described in the literature previously by others.
So, for example, if you give Bifidobacteria
consortia to Taconic mice, that improves checkpoint therapy in these mice.
So using this opportunity, we actually did similar experiments where we took
Taconic mice that have a non-reactive or less immunogenic microbiota and supplement
them with Enterococcus. And so this is what we see in this experiment.
Most mice
uptake Enterococcus at two logs lower levels of bacteria if you look at
the Enterococcus in the feces of these animals.
But despite the fact that they already have an intact microbiota, you can see that
actually SagA supplementation in faecalis or faecium
promotes anti-tumor activity, whereas faecalis alone doesn't do that. Okay?
So this experiment argues that you can, in principle, maybe supplement
mice or eventually humans that already have an intact microbiota that are maybe
non-immunogenic and not active enough and give them SagA-expressing
bacteria as an
adjuvant for immunotherapy.
Okay. So one other important aspect of this experiment is that we did sample the
microbiota composition throughout the experiment by 16S sequencing at that time.
And we noticed that Enterococcus supplementation, whether or not it expresses SagA,
didn't grossly change the microbiota of the recipient mice. Okay?
Arguing that we
likely are modulating the immune response of the mice and not the microbiota
composition when we give mice expressing SagA. Okay.
All right. Okay, so beyond just looking at faecalis and faecium, we did go
back and look at whether other Enterococcus species were enriched in checkpoint
therapy patients. So Laurence may remember this figure from her supplemental data,
where you see additional Enterococcus species that are correlated with better
checkpoint therapy response. Okay?
So beyond faecium, we notice Enterococcus raffae, durans,
scelenii. And actually interesting, faecalis is also positively correlated.
But I just showed you that it's not active in these mouse models. Okay.
So we wanted to revisit this more carefully between species.
And Mike Gilmore, who's an expert in Enterococcus
had done a very nice genomic comparison of Enterococcus isolates from the
environment and patients. So you can see that faecium can be
segregated into three major clades, B, A1,
and A2. You can see that the A2 clade is really the vancomycin-resistant,
antibiotic-resistant strains that are in patients, while the other two clades are
more probiotics.
But what's interesting is faecium is quite distantly related to
faecalis if you look at the whole genome level.
But some of the other Enterococcus species, like raffae, durans, actually
are quite similar to
Enterococcus faecium at the genome level.
And in fact, if you look in their genomes, they have SagA orthologs that are
greater than 80% sequence identity. Okay.
So we then went on to investigate the other Enterococcus species as well in these
mouse models. And in particular, if you look at SagA, the cell wall hydrolase
that I just described, the SagA active site is quite conserved,
but if you look amongst the Enterococcus species, SagA is really
more conserved between the
faecium, raffae, and durans and moonbae than
Enterococcus faecalis
orthologs. So these bacterial cell wall modians are in all
bacterial species, but they do have unique biochemical and expression
profiles that make them distinct. Okay?
If you look at the sequence strains of Enterococcus faecium, all the
SagA orthologs are almost 100% conserved. Okay?
And in vitro, when we purified recombinant versions of these enzymes, they behave
like the SagA from Enterococcus faecium, whereas the faecalis enzymes
have very different enzymatic
activityOkay. So in vitro
they have similar features. So in vivo, this is an experiment I've seen in the
antibody mouse model. If you give these other Enterococcus species to mice,
you can see they colonize mice comparably to faecium and faecalis.
But only the SagA expressing Enterococcus species, durans, and arae,
really can promote checkpoint therapy response.
And to date, none of the faecalis strains that we've tested in my laboratory can
really promote checkpoint therapy in mouse models.
So I would argue that even though faecalis is correlated with improved
responses, it's probably not functionally active.
Okay. So those studies showed that SagA expression is really sufficient
to drive
checkpoint therapy responses. But at the time, we didn't show that SagA is
required in the bacterium. And then I just will summarize and highlight this paper
we described recently where we finally made a deletion strain of SagA in the
commensal strain that we were working with.
And that commensal strain has a defect in cell separation of the bacteria.
They're viable, but they are incapable of activating NOD2
in cell culture experiments and do not promote checkpoint therapy response in vivo.
And actually, I didn't coordinate this with Rob, but Rob actually showed the data
earlier in his presentation, and it was already really nice, Rob, to
write this really nice preview for our paper in ELife a couple of years ago.
On the left here, I just wanted to show a cool image that my colleague, Raphael
Park at Scripps, he's an expert at cryotomography.
And you can see this is a cry-ET image of wild-type faecium
nicely in cell division. But a SagA deletion strain actually
is viable but doesn't divide properly.
You can see defects in cell separation of the bacterial cell wall, and you can see
that eventually one of the daughter cells actually dies during cell
division. So these enzymes are important for normal cell
division in bacteria, but also can shed immunogenic fragments that
are more
effective at stimulating host immune responses. Okay.
So all that work I showed you was really on a commensal strain of Enterococcus
species and a couple sort of
isolates of other Enterococcus species.
And we argued that SagA expression is sufficient and required for
promoting NOD2 immunity, ex vivo and in vivo.
But we didn't really explore this in much detail
beyond the commensal strain. And what I want to come back to before I
get back to this question about it being a probiotic is,
how can we use this information to
leverage it for immunotherapy? And most of you know, as clinicians, Enterococcus
cannot be used as a probiotic in humans.
So we leveraged the idea of using it potentially expressed in a
probiotic strain that could be used in humans.
And so Lactococcus lactis had been explored as a probiotic in humans previously.
And so in collaboration with RISE Therapeutics, we generated chromosomal knock-in
strains of wild type SagA, an active site mutant, and a secretion deficient
mutant to ask whether it would also be active in another bacterial
background.
And so this is the initial data we got in the same mouse model I showed you before,
antibiotic pretreatment, Lactococcus lactis supplementation.
And you can see that Lactococcus lactis, the probably the lactis you get in your
yogurt, isn't sufficient to promote checkpoint therapy response.
But if you express SagA in the chromosome of lactis, you can see nicely that the
purple strain nicely prevents tumor growth in combination with checkpoint therapy.
If you mutate the active site of SagA, the cysteine
residue that's important for catalytic activity, we totally abrogate the activity
of the engineered strain. And then we also made one other interesting strain where
we deleted the signal sequence to have it less secreted into the
media. That strain still seems to retain some anti-tumor activity,
and we don't know exactly what's going on there.
Maybe some aspect of the protein is still shed in the media, and it still has
residual activity.
But nonetheless, we can show from this experiment that SagA expression into an
otherwise inactive probiotic that's potentially useful in humans is
sufficient to promote checkpoint therapy response, and it requires the enzymatic
activity of the enzyme.
So it was pretty exciting, and in my lab, we had kind of joked for years that
we would make a yogurt, and we weren't really sort of
moving on that front. But then I moved to San Diego, and we wondered
maybe there would be beer that we can generate.
And actually, this is a Google search if you google probiotic beer.
So maybe one day I thought maybe we would make a hazy IPA that we're around here.
Okay.
So all joking aside, I would say that RISE Therapeutics actually did a quite
amazing job actually during the pandemic of moving this program forward.
And they're sort of specialized in producing GMP-grade
probiotic strains. And what they also did independently of us is show that
not only does Lactococcus lact
SagA sufficient in a preventative model for checkpoint therapy,
but they also showed that it was useful for a preventative therapeutic model where
they added the bacteria after the tumor was inoculated.
So to my delight, actually, in 2025, they got FDA
approval for an IND investigative vacation of this strain.
And then more recently,
a few months ago, they've started enrolling patients in a Phase 1 trial just to
look at safety. So we'll see. So I think for me, this has been
actually quite remarkable and very gratifying to see that we
went from a very exploratory study in C.
elegans to having potentially now this engineered strain being explored in humans.
So we'll have to stay tuned to see what happens. Okay.
So I really also like this figure from Laurence's review where she
contextualizes all the factors that impact immunotherapy.
And so with regard to looking at strain-specific differences in patients, I think
understanding whether these patients have SagA expressing Enterococcus will be
important for predicting toxicity or efficacy.
I'll say a little bit more about the vancomycin-resistant strains in a minute.
But beyond just at the bacterial level, I think understanding specific
genes and metabolites will be important as biomarkers for therapy.
And actually, Rob showed really nice data to look at immune peptide profiling in
blood to see the potential predictor of potential immunotherapy efficacy.
Beyond FMT, which others in the audience already noted potential challenges with
heterogeneity,
maybe a more engineered and precise probiotic such as SagA expressing
bacteria could be an alternative for FMTAnd then
I did say a lot about this on the personalized slide, but
understanding that Notch2 is required for Enterococcus being active
is super important for personalized medicine.
So people with loss-of-function mutations, and in particular carriers of these
mutations, wouldn't be great recipients for this type of therapy.
And we can talk about that more later if you guys are interested.
And from the drug discovery point of view, understanding the activity of the enzyme
also inspired us to look at the actual products of the activity.
So the mere peptides, I would argue, would be a good thing to
repurpose for immunotherapy. And in fact, there's already a drug called Rifametin
that's been used as a single agent for recurrent osteosarcoma.
So I'm trying to encourage companies and clinicians to
explore the combination therapy of this compound with checkpoint therapy.
We ourselves have also done some experiments looking at mere peptides
directly with combination therapy and also made a next generation of Notch2
synthetic agonists that we're trying to explore in the future.
I also want to mention that, and as Melody already pointed out, that
Enterococcus is also prevalent in CAR-T therapy, and that actually peptidylglycan
remodeling at the gene expression level is also correlated with better
responses in CAR-T patients.
So in my final few minutes, I want to just touch upon this whole issue of the
vancomycin-resistant strains, because really we only looked at this commensal
strain that we were characterizing in our lab.
And as many of you know, the Enterococcus resistant strains are actually quite
prevalent, which is really the most dominant type of Enterococcus you find in
patients. So the question we had was, is SAGA really active in
VRE strains? Are there any differences in VRE strains compared to commensal
strains?
So a quick look at the cancer patient data, and this is a nice
opportunity for us to analyze some metagenomic data from Trevor
Lawley's lab a few years ago, where they did metagenomic sequencing pre- and
post-checkpoint therapy response.
And when we query their data for vancomycin-resistant strains and
for SAGA expression, you can see that maybe 20% of the patients
actually have Enterococcus faecium in their patient cohort.
And if you look at SAGA expression, it's equally almost expressed in
vancomycin-resistant and sensitive strains, which we already knew
previously. But if you look at SAGA expression between
responsive patients to checkpoint therapy, we see that actually, in fact, patients
respond better to checkpoint therapy, have higher enrichment levels of SAGA in
their microbiota.
Arguing that maybe the presence of Enterococcus faecium and SAGA might actually be
a reasonable clinical correlate for predicting response.
But this is one patient cohort data set that we've analyzed that's
available.
If we go back and look at the Enterococcus
strains, whether they're vancomycin or sensitive or not, we can see that SAGA is
100% conserved between the commensal and
antibiotic-resistant strains. But beyond SAGA, there are other hydrolases that are
also expressed in these bacteria.
So what we call peptidylglycan hydrolase-2 is also highly conserved, maybe
arguably a core genomes
hydrolase. But it's interesting that vancomycin-resistant strains have acquired
additional cell wall hydrolases, which we wonder whether they would make them more
immunogenic or not. So we've begun to analyze whether SAGA is
also important in vancomycin-resistant strains.
So to get at that, we have a few vancomycin-resistant strains in my laboratory
already. So CON15 is the original commensal strain that my lab worked on
extensively. If you look at other VRE strains that are
from other patients, you can see that they have additional hydrolases.
So I just showed you these four that are prevalent, but they have up to 10
sometimes. So now, using better genetics, we've actually
knocked out SAGA in a VRE strain in my laboratory.
You can see here
the expression levels of SAGA in a wild-type VRE versus the knockout strain.
And we also made a complementation strain to show rescue of that activity.
In vitro, you can see that the deleted wild-type Enterococcus faecium activates
Notch2 very nicely. But the SAGA knockout strain loses Notch2
activation, and that's rescued with SAGA re-expression.
This correlates very nicely with the major metabolite that bacteria produce that
activates Notch2, this glycan disaccharide-Rhamnose dipeptide.
When we delete SAGA, we lose almost completely the major Notch2 agonist
in these bacteria.
In vivo,
I'll just show you that in a second, but if you look at Notch2 activation on cell
lines, you can see that, again, SAGA expression correlates with Notch2 activation.
And then this B16
mouse model for melanoma, you can see that in the VRE strain,
SAGA is still important for the immune modulation for checkpoint therapy.
And deletion loses that activity.
When we re-express SAGA in the chromosome at a neutral site, we
recover the antitumor activity, showing that SAGA, again, is necessary and
sufficient, even in a vancomycin-resistant strain that I think is more clinically
relevant.
Our initial immune profiling of the tumor-infiltrated lymphocytes shows that
bacteria
might colonize with Enterococcus. We see higher levels of activated CD8 T cells.
In the absence of SAGA, those levels go down.
And with re-expressing SAGA, they come back up to faecium
colonized levels.
So just to add on to what we've already described, we think that SAGA
expression in Enterococcus and faecium in commensal and
vancomycin-resistant strains are important.
This is conserved in some Enterococcus species, but not all of them.
And this is, I think, important for promoting checkpoint therapy, primarily
through, we think, the activation of Notch2 and myeloid cells that not only
promotes intestinal immunity but also serves as a mechanism to
promote T cell activation and likely promotes checkpoint therapy for reducing
tumor burden in vivo.
So in my last couple of minutes, I want to have something relatively new in my lab,
which is based on the work from Marcel van der Meer's lab, Rob, and actually
Melody. We've started to think about, okay, what is actually the real context of
which
VRE is really important? And of course, many of you guys know in the audience that
it's really in this context of allo-HDT transplantation and GVHD,
where Enterococcus is a major pathobiont heavily enriched in patients,
for which the activity of VRE is, I think it's still really
not well-described.
So
as Melody and Rob already alluded to in this really nice paper a few
years ago in the van der Meer lab, you can see
that-LAHCT patients that are on antibiotics
get blooms of pathobionts and in particular Faecium, which really are a
dominant intestinal species in these patients.
And the presence of Faecium correlates with poor survival in LAHT patients
and with GvHD. Okay. So we've been to wonder, is
immunomodulation
by SAGA in Enterococcus important also in LAHT
in mouse models? Okay.
And I should also mention that there's this beautiful study also showed that
lactase metabolite is a major factor that's important for VAV
intestinal colonization.
Okay, so we've just started doing this.
This is really fresh data that's only a few weeks old.
But Adriana Turner, a new postdoc in my laboratory, and Stas Daikie, an
immunologist in my lab, have set up LAHT models in my laboratory.
In this particular experiment,
both mice are in the donor on black six background, but they're MHC
matched using the black six recipient and LP donor
mice. And when we do this experiment, and we compare
a vire strain versus a SAGA mutant.
These mice are pre-treated with ampicillin first before irradiation, okay?
And then we look at their survival over time.
And what we noticed, as you can see here, is that mice that are colonized with a
native vire strain,
this is a relatively mild GvHD model, okay,
are doing okay. But actually in the absence, okay, of SAGA in the SAGA
knockout strain, actually, these mice do much worse, okay.
It suggested that SAGA in this vire strain actually provides a
benefit. And that's correlated. That's not really due to just
bacterial loads, even though the SAGA knockout strain doesn't grow as well, we see
sufficient numbers of bacteria colonizing in the mice. Okay.
So this is actually a quite exciting result in the laboratory.
I would have to say at the outset of this experiment, I didn't know what would
happen because it's possible that activation of NOD2 could exacerbate an immune
response and make GvHD worse, okay?
Or the opposite, which is what I'm showing you, the loss of NOD2 activity through
the bacteria can be beneficial. Okay, so this is quite interesting.
And we don't really know what's going on at the moment, but I'll just cite some
important previous literature. So many of you know that NOD2, this immune receptor,
is a major risk factor for Crohn's disease.
And in Crohn's disease, the loss of NOD2, the absence of sensing the
microbiota has compromised intestinal barrier and the microbiota get out of
control, induced inflammation. Okay.
There are other papers in the field where NOD2-deficient animals that
are not challenged at homeostatic levels, NOD2 plays a tolerogenic
role by modulating myeloid cells. Okay.
And this very nice old paper from Marcel van der Meer's lab showed that
actually NOD2 has a beneficial role in antigen-presenting
cells in graft versus host disease, and this is a follow-up study on older data
that shows that correlations of NOD2 polymorphisms have an
impact on transplantation. So I think our data is largely
consistent with this idea that NOD2 is protective and beneficial, okay?
And at the moment, this is kind of the working model we have in the laboratory that
even though in the context of checkpoint therapy where there's antigen in tumor
cells, we're promoting an immune response to clear tumors.
In the absence, okay, in this GvHD model of antigen, we're directly
promoting regulatory T cells that are tolerogenic.
And those tolerogenic T cells might be suppressing the LAHT
activity of T cells. So this is still a working model at the moment in the
laboratory, but this is how we're thinking about the role of NOD2 as being
a protective immune sensor of the microbiota and how Enterococcus.
In some cases, it might be beneficial.
We haven't explained why Enterococcus might be detrimental yet, and this is to
come. But at least in this context, we think that the role of NOD2
activation of Enterococcus is beneficial, okay, and likely due to gut protection,
which we're still studying.
So let me just close with that and thank the people that are involved in this work.
I try to highlight the initial sort of key investigators in the beginning.
But the folks in yellow are the people in my lab that are continuing to explore
this. And I want to acknowledge all my collaborators over the years that worked on
the NOD2 SAGA project and our collaborators, and these people for funding
and you for your attention. Rob, thank you again for the invitation, and I'm happy
to take any questions.
Andrea Faciabene from University of Pennsylvania.
I see you talk about vancomycin-resistant
Enterococcus, right?
Yes.
You compare. So I expect that when you treat patients
with vanco, you should have an upreg-- more of this
bacteria. So I'm wondering if in your experiment, did you compare
ever the treatment with vancomycin directly
comparing with the SAGA in
combination with
immunotherapy? Did you do anything like that?
Yeah. That's a good question. So actually, I think Melody showed a paper in CAR
T-cell therapy where they gave vancomycin, and that was a poor outcome, if I
remember correctly, with vancomycin treatment.
So we're actually quite interested in this experiment as well
because the addition of vancomycin resistance can also modulate
the cell wall of the bacteria. And so actually, we just deleted the
vancomycin resistance pathway in the bacteria and are in the process of doing the
experiment of the bacteria with or without vancomycin in vivo. Okay.
So it's an excellent question. I don't have the answer for you yet, but I hope I
will in a few months. Okay.
Great question.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Howard, I was going to ask,
is Enterococcus the primary source of NOD2 ligands within the
microbiome?
Good question.
We haven't done a proper experiment to really assess that in a sort of
community context if we remove or put vancomycin.
I would argue in our supplementation experiments, we can elevate the level of NOD2
agonist by Enterococcus supplementation.
But in normal microbiota between patient populations,
there's probably other bacteria that can contribute NOD2 activation, right?
And certainly, there are probiotic strains that people have identified that can
also mediate NOD2 activation. But in a sort of complex
community, I can't really tell you if that's the only species that is really
dominant for NOD2.That's an excellent question. Yeah.
Your tectonic mouse data suggests that you
don't need very much of the muramyl dipeptides to be
produced, presumably, right?
Presumably. But we still give the mice a lot of bacteria.
So, I would say
they're supplemented way more than what we would find in human
diversity.
I see.
I think there's a question on the right over there.
I apologize if I missed this and you already said it, but you brought up the
concept of exogenously administering NOD2 agonists as
an alternate strategy, and I'm wondering if your lab's already
demonstrated that exogenous NOD2 agonism can phenocopy the
results you've seen.
Yes. Yeah. So actually, that's published in the end of our paper.
And synthetic ones also
serve as adjuvants for checkpoint therapy.
I just didn't have time to talk about it today in this presentation. Thank you.
Well, very nice talk. I was wondering if you looked at
the trained immunity concept and
if you can demarginate some kind
of precursors of granulomonocytic
cells when you load your mice with
this
Lactococcus lactis SAG or
the other E. fischeri.
Yeah. Stimulating myeloid cells is, I think,
interesting, but also that some of the bacterial and their metabolites might go
back to the bone marrow and improve differentiation of granulocytes and
other TC. So
we started to look at that. We do see some increased levels of
sort of mature cells from the bone marrow.
So
now whether that directly contributes to the antitumor immunity, we don't really
know yet. But this idea of training immunity, I think with the microbiota, I think
is certainly a very valid hypothesis.
And whether we can leverage that and promote the training immune response, I think
this could be very exciting, actually. Yeah.
One question in terms of your allotransplant preclinical data that you showed.
So you looked at a minor mismatched model.
Have you evaluated the impact of SAG in a major
mismatched model, do you think? Yeah, I'll just leave it there.
No. Yeah, that's on our to-do list right now.
Okay.
It's ongoing. So
we chose this minor mismatched model actually because of this old paper from
Marcel's lab where we wanted to see a more distinct difference
between-- We were initially worried that the disease symptom is so
severe from the mismatched model that we wouldn't see a difference.
And also, we wanted to be able to do that in the black sex background to look at
NOD2. So that's why we chose the matched model initially.
But we definitely have to go back and do the mismatched model.
So, okay. All right.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you, Howard.
So, on behalf of my other speakers, thank you very much
for educating us and teaching us. Those were phenomenal
talks. And thank you to the audience for being here and
asking great questions. So with that, I'd like to close the session. Thanks.
Thank you.